así no sería el abandonado en el campo.
Mis ojos muy cerrados
así no vería al trigo siendo separado de la cizaña.
Y luego una voz resonó sobre nosotros:
«Amén».
Se había terminado.
Miré al reloj.
Era más de medianoche.
Miré a los feligreses Mayores
cuyo salvador no apareció;
eran muy orgullosos para mostrar su desilusión;
habían creído demasiado y por mucho tiempo
para empezar a dudar ahora.
Pero yo me sentía mal por ellos.
Habían sido engañados,
embaucados, burlados
y yo había pasado por lo mismo que ellos.
Había hecho sus oraciones,
había resistido a la tentación tanto como pude.
había sumergido mi cabeza no una, sino dos veces,
irritando mi nariz en esa pila bautismal.
Yo había creído.
¿Ahora qué?
Regresé a casa justo a tiempo para encender el televisor
y ver a Peter Jennings anunciar el nuevo milenio
que entraba en curso en el mundo.
Se me ocurrió que, de alguna forma, habría sido extraño
que Jesús regresara una y otra vez
basado en todas las zonas horarias.
(Risas)
Y esto me hizo sentir aún más ridículo,
herido, en realidad.
Pero allí en esa noche, no dejé de creer.
Sólo creía una cosa nueva:
que era posible no creer.
Era posible que las respuestas estuvieran mal,
que las mismas preguntas fueran equivocadas.
Y ahora, donde una vez hubo una montaña de fe,
surgía justo bajo sus cimientos,
un manantial de duda,
Un manantial que presagiaba ríos.
Puedo dar al origen del drama de mi vida
en esa noche en aquella iglesia
cuando mi salvador no vino por mí,
cuando lo que creía con tanta certeza
resultó ser, si no una mentira,
entonces una verdad incompleta.
Y aunque muchos de Uds. se prepararon para el 2000 de formas diferentes,
estoy convencido de que están aquí
porque cierta parte de ustedes ha hecho lo mismo que yo
desde el origen de este nuevo siglo,
desde que mi madre partiera, mi padre se apartara
y mi Señor se rehusara a venir.
Y extendí mi mano,
buscando algo en que creer.
Me aferré cuando llegué a Yale a los 18,
con la fe de que mi viaje desde Oak Cliff, Texas
fuera una oportunidad de dejar atrás los retos que había conocido,
los sueños rotos y las almas deshechas que había visto.
Pero cuando regresé a casa en unas vacaciones de invierno,
con mi rostro estampado en el piso,
mis manos atadas tras mi espalda
y con un arma presionando mi cabeza,
Supe que incluso la mejor educación no podía salvarme.
Me aferré cuando me presenté en Lehman Brothers
como practicante en el 2008.
(Risas)
Tan esperanzado...
Que llamaba a casa para decir a mi familia
que nunca más seríamos pobres.
(Risas)
Pero cuando vi que este templo financiero
se venía abajo ante mis ojos,
Supe que ni aún el mejor empleo podía salvarme.
Me aferré al presentarme en Washington como un joven miembro de comité
que había escuchado un llamado desde Illinois,
que decía: «Ya ha pasado mucho tiempo,
pero en esta elección, el cambio ha llegado a Estados Unidos».
Pero cuando el Congreso se estancó en un punto,
y el país se desmoronó
y la fe y el cambio ya sabían a una cruel broma,
Supe que aún la Segunda Venida Política
no podría salvarme.
Me había arrodillado fielmente ante el altar del Sueño Americano,
rezando a los dioses de mi tiempo
al dios del éxito,
del dinero,
y del poder.
Pero una y otra vez,
llegaba la medianoche, y yo abría mis ojos
para ver que todos esos dioses habían muerto.
Y desde ese cementerio,
empezaba a buscar una vez más,
no porque era valiente,
sino porque sabía que bien podría creer
o morir.
Así que hice una peregrinación aún a otra Mecca,
a Harvard Business School,
(Risas)
esta vez, sabiendo que no podía simplemente aceptar la salvación
que afirmaba ofrecer.
No, yo sabía que habría más trabajo que hacer.
El trabajo empezó en el oscuro rincón de una concurrida fiesta,
en la noche de un anticipado y triste invierno en Cambridge,
cuando entre amigos nos hicimos la pregunta
que los jóvenes en búsqueda de algo real se hacen
por mucho tiempo:
«¿Qué tal si hacemos un viaje largo?»
(Risas)
No sabíamos a dónde ir o cómo llegaríamos allí,
pero sabíamos que teníamos que hacerlo
Porque en nuestra vida anhelábamos, como Jack Kerouac escribió,
«escabullirnos en la noche y desaparecer en algún lugar»
y descubrir lo que todos hacían
en todo el país.
Así que aunque había otras voces que decían
que el riesgo era muy alto y la ganancia muy baja,
seguimos de cualquier forma.
Recorrimos casi 13 000 km a lo largo de EE. UU. en el verano de 2013,
cruzamos los pastizales de Montana, una Detroit desolada,
los pantanos de Nueva Orleans,
donde hallamos y trabajamos con hombres y mujeres
dedicados a pequeños negocios
que les rendían buenos resultados.
Y al haber sido formado en el capitalismo occidental
esto nos dio una idea revolucionaria.
(Risas)
Y esta idea se difundió,
convirtiéndose en una ONG llamada MBA Across America,
un movimiento que me trajo aquí al escenario de hoy.
Esto se extendió porque descubrimos en esta generación un deseo
de propósito, de sentido.
Se extendió porque encontramos incontables emprendedores
de costa a costa de Estados Unidos
quienes estaban creando empleos, cambiando vidas
y necesitaban un poco de ayuda.
Pero si acaso soy honesto; se extendió también
porque luché para difundirla.
No había distancia a la cual no iba
a predicar este mensaje,
para contar con más gente que creyera
que podríamos vendar las heridas de un país herido,
en un negocio social al mismo tiempo.
Pero era este viaje de evangelismo
que me condujo a un evangelio muy diferente,
que he venido a compartir con ustedes hoy.
Empezó una noche hace casi un año
en el Museo de Historia Natural de la Ciudad de Nueva York,
en una gala para egresados de la Harvard Business School.
Bajo una réplica a escala de una ballena,
me senté con los titanes de nuestro tiempo
mientras celebraban con sus colegas, sus hazañas.
Había orgullo en ese salón
donde el patrimonio neto y sus activos administrados
sobrepasaban los 500 billones de dólares.
Contemplamos todo lo que habíamos hecho,
y era bueno.
(Risas)
Pero aconteció,
que dos días después,
tuve que viajar camino a Harlem,
donde terminé estableciéndome en una granja urbana
que una vez fue un lote baldío,
escuchando a un hombre llamado Tony hablarme de los niños
que se veían allí a diario.
Todos ellos vivían bajo extrema pobreza.
Muchos de ellos cargaban sus cosas en una mochila
para evitar perderlas en un albergue.
Algunos de ellos vinieron al programa de Tony,
llamado Harlem Grown,
para recibir la única comida que tenían cada día.
Tony me contó que empezó Harlem Grown con dinero de su pensión,
después de 20 años como taxista.
Me contó que no se asignaba un salario,
porque a pesar del éxito, el programa pasaba por apuros.
Me contó que tomaría cualquier ayuda
que pudiera conseguir.
Y yo estaba allí como esa ayuda.
Pero cuando dejé a Tony, sentí el ardor y el sabor de las lágrimas
brotando de mis ojos.
Sentí el pesar de la revelación
que en una noche podía estar en un lugar,
donde unos cientos de personas tenían 500 billones de dólares,
y estar en otro lugar, dos días después,
a sólo 50 cuadras de la carretera,
donde un hombre iba sin pago alguno
para que un niño tenga su única comida del día.
Y no era la deslumbrante desigualdad la que me hacía querer llorar,
no era la idea del hambre, de los niños sin hogar,
no era odio hacia el 1%
o pena hacia el 99%.
No, yo estaba enfadado porque me había dado cuenta
que yo era una diálisis
para un país que necesitaba de un trasplante de riñón.
Me di cuenta que mi historia representaba a todos aquellos
que se esperaba que se levantaran por sus propios medios,
aún cuando no tenían recurso alguno;
vi que mi organización representaba
toda la ayuda estructural y sistemática que nunca iba a Harlem
o a Appalachia o al Noveno Distrito;
que mi voz representaba todas esas voces
que parecían tan incultas, tan descuidadas, tan desamparadas.
Y lo triste de eso,
era que la pena me cubría
como la pena de sentarse frente al televisor,
observando a Peter Jennings anunciar el nuevo milenio
una
y otra
y otra vez más.
Había sido engañado,
embaucado,
burlado,
Pero esta vez, el falso salvador era yo.
Verán, he recorrido un largo camino desde ese altar
en la noche que creí que el mundo acabaría,
de un mundo donde la gente hablaba en lenguas
y veía el sufrimiento como un acto necesario de Dios
y tomaba un texto como la verdad infalible.
Sí, he llegado tan lejos
que estoy exactamente de donde comencé.
Porque simplemente no es cierto decir
que vivimos en la era de la poca fe,
no, hoy creemos tanto como en cualquier otro momento anterior a este.
Algunos pueden creer en la profecía de Brené Brown
o de Tony Robbins.
Podemos creer en la biblia del New Yorker
o de la revista Harvard Business Review.
Podemos creer más profundamente
cuando adoramos justo aquí en la iglesia de TED,
pero queremos desesperadamente creer,
Necesitamos creer.
Hablamos en lenguas de carismáticos líderes
que prometen resolver nuestros problemas.
Vemos el sufrimiento como un acto necesario del dios del capitalismo,
tomamos el texto del progreso tecnológico
como la verdad infalible.
Y difícilmente vemos el precio humano que pagamos
cuando fallamos al cuestionar un ladrillo,
porque tememos que pueda sacudir nuestros cimientos.
Pero si están afectados
por las cosas inadmisibles que hemos llegado a aceptar,
entonces debe ser el tiempo de cuestionarse.
Así que no tengo un evangelio de disrupción o innovación
o de un triple objetivo.
No tengo un evangelio de fe que compartir con ustedes hoy, de hecho.
Tengo y ofrezco un evangelio de la duda.
El evangelio de la duda no te pide que dejes de creer.
te pide que creas algo nuevo:
que es posible no creer.
Es posible que nuestras respuestas estén mal,
es posible de que las mismas preguntas estén erradas.
Sí, el evangelio de la duda nos dice que es posible que nosotros,
en este escenario, en este salón,
estemos equivocados.
Porque allí surge la pregunta: «¿Por qué?»
Con todo el poder que poseemos en nuestras manos,
¿Por qué la gente aún está sufriendo tanto?
Esta duda me lleva a compartir que mi organización,
MBA Across America,
la estamos cerrando.
Hemos prescindido del personal y cerramos las puertas
y compartiremos este modelo gratuitamente
con cualquiera que se vea en poder de hacer este trabajo
sin que esperen nuestro permiso.
Este duda me obliga
a renunciar al rol de salvador
que algunos me han asignado,
porque el tiempo es muy corto y las posibilidades muy grandes
como para esperar Segundos Advenimientos,
cuando la verdad es que aquí no habrá milagros.
Y esta duda, me alimenta,
me da esperanza
que cuando los problemas nos agobien,
cuando el camino dispuesto para nosotros parezca conducirnos a la muerte,
cuando nuestros doctores no traigan confort a nuestras heridas,
no será nuestra fe ciega,
no, será nuestra humilde duda
la que traiga una pequeña luz a la oscuridad de nuestras vidas
y de nuestro mundo
y nos permita alzar nuestra voz para susurrar,
o para gritar
o para decir sencillamente,
muy sencillamente,
«Debe haber otra forma».
Gracias.
(Aplausos)